hey Clark today's the day it's in the
back I'll go get it once again a Direct
Connect 300 baud modem how much don't
worry I'm using my allowance plus Clark
gave me a healthy discount for helping
with his application of medical school
okay
what's a modem dude it allows me to
connect my computer to other computers
that also have one why would you need to
do that so I can share my scientific
ideas with academics all over the world
it's like the cybernetic version of the
Algonquin Round Table I don't know what
that means that's okay
you're still my dad and I'm genetically
obligated to love you someone responded
to a theory I posted on the physics
bulletin board called my work flawed
that's rude
lemon I can't push you around that's why
I did a baseball practice I'd rather not
resort to name-calling it usually gets
me stuff somewhere uncomfortable that's
in person or people no you're pathetic
and weak that's true this is completely
anonymous I can say whatever I want
without fear of physical retaliation
thanks and on that day my sister created
the first Internet flame war
[Music]
it's just so easy all you do is type in
the use net address Sai dot theory dot
is X dot research dot one
careful in wargames matthew broderick
almost broke the wall the only thing i'm
gonna be blowing up is this fellow's
flimsy argument that was one of my
classic jokes feel for you laughs see
like magic
[Music]